[Music]
appreciate that
sorry for missing it and thank you about
this guy hacks for the sub
i was very close i mean if i just moved
a millisecond more slowly
that was very close i was dialed in at
the end for sure
it became bully it became a second game
okay i got very lucky there to even get
that
yeah this is supposed to be slightly
better for white
oh my god that was so close
okay so he provokes he provokes
he provokes a6 which is good for me
[Music]
i have an instagram but i don't i
haven't uploaded anything yet
thank you thank you bae 25 months much
appreciated thank you very much
oh my god that was crazy
yeah but now i'm worse again i'm still
thinking about that game
and eli reza is not okay let's go here
this is just bad for me
hmm
let's go back yeah that was very poor
opening
um yeah this is just completely lost
unfortunately
yeah xcc versus pokeman's gonna be
really interesting
i think the game start at 3 3
so 40 minutes from now okay that might
have been
i guess he sacrificed it but this gives
me an exchange problem is i'm still lost
he definitely blundered that but it's
still very bad
amazingly okay i kind of have to trade
the rooks here
xqc game got postponed oh because
someone's in texas
i i'm not commentating today
i'm not sure who is but i know that i'm
i mean as far as i know i'm not
xqc's in texas yeah hopefully he's safe
yeah that sucks and then levy yeah so
anna and levy today
yeah this is still bad for me but i'm
somehow
trying to hold on in this position
the ship c4 is a key move okay i'm
trying to
hold on here
this is a good move for me no now it
should be drawable
wow lots of oh tang is streaming too
you gotta take this yeah take the juicer
and then
should be drawable
yeah what's happening sucks
what's up shark shark is uniquely
qualified to confirm that opinion and
i've wondered yeah
i just splendored this crazy insane move
that
probably wins unless i can stop his
pawn
did you just miss that move i'm somehow
holding on for now
oh my god oh no but i was losing i
couldn't do anything against oh rookie
no i was lost he was threatening to
promote when the rock
oh my god i'm just not seeing the board
today
still if i had more time i'd have some
chances here
that's horrible
yeah unbelievable
after all that recovery just a blunder
like this thank you wolf ben
yeah i'm down to play guitar for this
game
yeah he's deciding whether to go for
[Music]
berlin
yeah just incredible to lose that
i didn't really okay fine whatever let's
check let's test this berlin
um thumb wrestling world champion
basically
okay let's try this interesting line
finally i could remember it i analyzed
this a while ago
yeah now white is supposed to be
slightly better here i think after
bishop g5
he's playing bullet i mean i would be
totally down to play him in bullet
obviously maybe i'd give him a slightly
better value for the rating
he's trying to play after yeah i'm down
to play after i finish this game for
sure
i just need to run to the bathroom but
after that i'm totally down
bullet or blitz 100 percent
[Music]
i don't know what we're doing yet but
we're it's gonna be fun
okay that was another mistake by me
typical annoyingly reza move
that is an annoying move okay let's
bring the king up
yeah i can see
okay wait isn't this a free pawn
a frond
no it's not of course he has some some
crazy stuff there
i mean maybe we can play blitz then we
don't have to play bullet
i mean he was just playing some game
blitz
yeah this is not looking good
that is also true
yeah there's just a machine okay maybe
here
because if he checks me i can go kg2
this is an important resource
yeah but now a car is going to want to
adopt him
okay i'm 20 seconds up on already which
basically means equal time
given how fast he is
[Music]
this one i blundered
okay i think this is fine for me because
i wonder i give up c2 but it's it's okay
thank you fraser arena okay i'm just
gonna go for this i
feel like it's okay for me but i'm not
sure
pro maybe it's lost who knows and now i
thought i have a key resource g5 and h5
g5 takes h5 g4 g4
he's got g4 then but maybe i start with
h5 for that reason
and then we go g5 oh but he goes c3
okay c3 oh no he's going to go cb he's
going to promote chuck
gonna be very careful here not splinter
my queen
there's just no way he's gonna make it
that's what we call a blitz game
yeah that's insane all right i keep
lettering d5 here
he's absolutely immersed i mean he just
never never
you can never get away with anything you
know against ever
he will punish everything
any little move order slip up i mean i'm
not like in big trouble here
i've got to be a little bit careful
that's unbelievable he promotes and
defensive i mean i saw that
that he would run out of mo that my king
was trapped but his pawn was hanging
and by promoting he um he should have
made a knight by promoting he defends
that pawn
i mean it's crazy
yeah i mean thanks it's just insane
stalemate is like such an underrated
tool of defense against time pressure
but it's uh it's not how i like to
how i like to play but it is what it is
we've had some close games and but the
way that he was able to get i mean
nobody
yeah but this is just bad i mean i
played so poorly this opening
i just made one little sloppy move and
that's literally that's all it takes and
you're lost
because you i mean he won't make a
single mistake in these positions
i just gotta hold strong here i mean if
i think it was auto promotion and also
you couldn't really there's nothing you
could do you would have lost on time
and would have been a draw anyway
so i'm worse here but
it's not a crisis
there's just nothing you can do at that
point
not that i'm proud of that i mean it's
just
i mean now b5 i think is maybe a tiny
tiny bit inaccurate because it keeps it
the knight is now undefended
he's still better though it's just not
not a big deal
we can try this just to enable of course
i'm looking at this
elementary tactic but on the other hand
i have a rook lift
and the short clip doesn't lead anywhere
unacceptable miss there
just child's play things i'm missing
only a pawn down but it's horrible
position
also as a blender
completely unacceptable
yeah the rook lift doesn't doesn't do
anything
now i need it now i need another miracle
i need wait what
okay this i'm not sure about
okay he wants this he wants to trick me
here
oh yeah this is just very strong i guess
um i see what his ideas it's good good
for him
yeah it's gonna double this is over i
mean this was over the moment i i
played that opening move
[Music]
it's no tricks zero tricks here
not zero but realistically zero
yeah one sloppy move and you that's it
yeah this is just over
i mean
yeah it's accuracy in that game it's
probably like 99 percent
[Music]
i'm actually curious maybe somebody
could check
[Music]
yeah it takes takes g4 as possible
we need to i don't know i guess i take
i guess i go here
[Music]
97.3 yeah a meager 97.3
less than charlie yesterday
yeah i'm losing completely losing the
threat i think
okay wait what if i take oh he has got
this and it's mate
what am i doing i mean it's just
incredible
[Music]
no and now i'm playing with a 1700.
[Music]
queen h5 is probably good okay goes
there
well i have no choice my moves are
forced
queen d6 queen d5 probably winning for
him although it's not
entirely obvious and it kind of is
though
i guess he just takes no he doesn't
doesn't feel comfortable with it
i'm surprised honestly i thought that i
guess f5 ah but then queen d1
i'm surprised he didn't go for the oh 95
is probably some sort of a mate
king okay king g6 queen e8 grenade king
f6
knight h7 king of i'm sure there is a
mate there but
not quite seeing it yet
i'm sure i will
knight h7 king f5 queen of fate king e4
and then my king runs to d3 and then
he gets a million pawns but as long as i
have this before pawn break
i have some chances practically speaking
the amount of okay you also can go here
but that's absolutely anybody's game ah
but no it's not
it was queen e2 yeah this is so hard to
defend though
okay i can take the pawn he's
threatening queen
he's not actually wait i can play queen
g2
let's go queen g2 takes takes
b4 takes c3 and if he goes
king f2 then b3 whoa that might actually
be a brilliant idea
that actually might be a brilliant idea
oh no oh no he stops with the knight but
wait wait maybe i missed that of course
but wait a second
this might still be winning so b3 takes
takes
knight f3 okay so bc
knight f3 takes and of course he
wait no bc takes takes
knight e1 king e3 king f1 king d2
king d1 probably this is good for me
it's the only move really
and then i might have to under promote
actually if he goes takes king f2 i'll
make a knight there in the end
king f2 c2 and i make a knight that's
force
it's a amazing end game maybe that's
winning
i don't know wait
yeah if i make a queen it promotes
that's why i don't have auto queen on
maybe it's a dryer i have to push
not sure what to do
amazing
okay
that was a very nice game actually i i
that was that was good
good calculation there
yeah bishop h5 is a new thing i think i
go here
i make a knight he forks my king and
queen so this is a very um
common well it's not very common but it
exists this idea of making a knight
in order to avoid a fork
but it's i mean it's very pretty when it
happens because
just making a night in general when you
have to is pretty one of my favorite
concepts in chess
and it's very easy to understand i mean
like if you actually look at the
position you will see that there is a
fork
okay white is better here but it's never
these positions are
can easily turn around so we gotta we
gotta attack probably bishop f6 is good
for him
i'm not i don't i'm not i don't think
i'm commentating again
i mean i might look at the games but i'm
not i don't think i'm being i'm the
official commentator
no that was that was i usually don't
give myself any credit but that was i'm
proud of that one that was a really nice
game
now we're gonna go after him
okay unfortunately it appears that i
blundered
okay but that that is unexpected
i guess he calculated g6 now this again
gets very sharp queen g5
king h shade i suppose is fine for him
is there any alternatives to queen g5 oh
maybe knight e3 he wants
no no not king h8 i guess
g8 she's fine there i mean i'm slightly
better
no knight e3 okay the reason
ali riza so queen h6 wait but i thought
i have
f5 do i have f5 king h8 takes six
complicated f5 i guess yes
yeah it's super super complex
and i don't have any time unfortunately
i mean i kind of have to try this not
much of a choice
rook f4 maybe
rogue g8 so if i go fg goes f g queen h6
rook g7 is fine i don't know i'm gonna
lose on time
i don't know what to do
guess i go here
rook g89 g7
i have a minute it's fine
i promise he has knight f5 i think
knight d5
he takes what's his idea oh no no i
blended the rook
wait but
[Music]
amazing it's not clear though
it's not obvious that he's winning i'm
an attack
i don't have any time though
look
rascal
let's go here oh hope that he doesn't
have more than a draw
oh he actually might because i there's a
mine square
i can't let his queen get to e3 with
check that's the only
only condition oh he defends
i have not have f5 it's gonna give me a
million checks here
oh no no that doesn't work oh what am i
doing
yeah amazingly he found a defense
now he's winning incredible i mean he
deserved that one
did everything i could just absolutely
unbelievable calculation by him i wonder
if i was ever winning
just a computer
i wonder if i was ever winning there
yeah much better but not winning
yep rook h5 loses
yeah i mean oh gee h
wins ah gh not gf come on
so obvious gh not gf
unbelievable back to yeah
incredible
yeah just unbelievable yeah i made the
i made the natural move but i was
winning there of course
just can't make any mistakes against him
at all
oops
i should miss that
i should not miss that
bad very bad okay but it's fine
i played well otherwise
he's not playing well in the opening
with any turns on
his inner stock fish
holy reza fish
d5 it seems like it's
very risky positionally but i guess
he understands these positions much
better than me
yeah the other the biggest problem was
that i played
glacially i mean i had to he he took
about two seconds to calculate all these
lines
so it was a deserved victory
okay let's bring all the pieces bringing
all the toys to the nursery party
ali reza is the future there's no doubt
about that just watching him
calculate this like he's faster than
magnus
i've never seen or heard of such
calculation before in my life
it's like the guy his intuition is
insane
and he also can calculate anything to
any length and he calculates it
instantly without any blunders
so virtually no blunders of course he
also he blunders but it's so rare you
can count it on like
i mean you can never beat him with just
a blunder on his end
much harder to plan bullet elias is
i think probably magnus is better in
bullet maybe right now but only for
another couple months
he's going to surpass him if he
continues to work hard
and i'm not just saying that to like
just say it i really believe it i've
been saying it for a while actually
i could have taken the pawn maybe but
that wasn't probably wasn't a good idea
he's capable of making positional
misjudgments and stuff but he also is
very young
dude it's not a mix of me i'm like
nowhere near the top
i'm i am but i'm immortal compared to
these these gods
it's just for me it's just an honor to
play them and
lose to them so occasionally sneak in a
win
hmm not easy
yeah but i thought i have this move see
this i saw i thought i have this move
and
the key is that he doesn't have a check
yeah i think he loses here
all right what's self-deprecating about
saying that it's an honor to play them
and the fact is i'm 150th in the world
and he's like third
fit like 10th so i'm not sure i see
where
self-def deprecating part is
well compared to them in classical i am
basically nothing that is true
that's not to say i i never said i'm
nothing overall
well i think i outplayed him there i
know i mean he blundered in the end but
he was in some trouble
yeah these positions are hard to play
for both sides
should i know that's too early
thanks well right now i'm streaming
stuff
okay so we're gonna try to get the night
around
i mean if you disagree with me random
wings but feel free to
voice your concerns well he's got
pressure and i've got an attack
so a single mistake will send either of
us tumbling down
eric the red no and they won't
unfortunately
i'm phasing out coaching private pushing
a little bit
my current students are safe
well public coaching is kind of what i
do right
thank you moosby
okay my plan here is to
to shift down the bishop
and then
queen h5
well that's just how i was brought up
random wings and that's just how
how i am
that's just how i was raised i mean so
no it's not burnt out but i i need to
leave a little bit of time for myself
which i'm not really doing right now
look it's not about more room i'm i'm
surprised
my point is not coming across to some
people
there's nothing to do with money
i would like to teach everybody but
there's 24 hours in a day and
you know
i don't know how to explain it but
anyways i gotta focus
yeah i sacked a piece in unsound but i
have some chances here
group sessions is basically twitch i
mean maybe at some point
i mean i think i'm in control of it and
i'll i'll make the proper decisions
yeah this is over this one i blundered
away
well i i do have students and yeah
thanks random wings
yeah that was just a very bad game
you know definitely season two would be
great but
we're thinking about it well what do you
mean why not because they're
professional chess players and they
expect to be paid well for their time
even if i understand i i know you do
but but some people don't and i'm just
going to be very blunt here
and and this is not this is not an
accused i know that people now interpret
everything like an accusation
some people but this is not an
accusatory statement it's just sort of a
statement of
fact and
thank you america and i'm not trying to
guilt anyone or and nor does it diminish
my gratitude for
everything people do for me
but there are certain people who do
expect
sort of just this stuff to kind of just
happen
um and who don't fully understand that
like
people's livings are tied into this
all right so let's see yeah this is a
bad position right out of the opening
anyways enough on that topic thank you
husker appreciate it
[Music]
yeah this is just a quick loss probably
if i'm not something crazy doesn't
happen
okay how exactly does he win though it's
not clear
okay i gotta watch the fork potentially
so he wants knight c2
like that would be like yeah
should have gotten five in the last one
maybe thank you 200 appreciate it man
thanks for the fat 10 gift subs pikachu
oh nobody's a downer
night before yeah
yep learning from critical yeah now we
blundered it
you blunder9 what did i tell you guys
i told you the moment he he allowed it
with the bishop defending that that he
might blunder it at some point
but okay one of us has to win a game
with white it's unbelievable neither of
us is able to win a game of white
no but he was already he was in trouble
he was in trouble because i was
threatening bishop d3
again it was not it was not a good
position for him already
so okay so like i've seen people somehow
like take here and get a better position
which is weird because it opens the file
for him
no don't read fundamental just openings
at all that's not necessary
at your level
this is exactly what we practiced for
i don't know exactly what i'll be doing
with kit he will i think he will try to
get a game with a scammer
but it will be fun so i mean tune in if
you don't like it
no problem
but the problem with what i previously
said is i also it's a very fine line
because
when you stream for example it's very
unfair to expect people to contribute
anything and it's a very bad one of the
worst feelings is watching somebody and
feeling guilty while you're watching
that person
because they're railing on about how
nobody supports them which is ridiculous
um so it's
it's it's easy to imply that and i'm not
trying to imply that
mike on ol thank you
especially because it's far from the
case
o c o w a thank you
o c o w a
lots of subs today
yeah once again i'm worse yeah neither
of us is able to play with white clearly
today
good time to reactivate the alerts
yeah maybe v3 maybe that's the that's
the solution
to the world's problems
16 17 i mean fundamental chess opening's
not the only opening book
i think larry kaufman's books on the
opening are much better for like
semi-beginners
is there more practical i think i should
go here and try to quickly go g4
it's very taxing on my position or maybe
i should go
here try to go bishop f6
yeah bobby fisher's gcs is awesome i
think i didn't read it but it's good
yeah this is an l upper l probably
i think jerry sewman is great i think
there are some people who speak of him
like he's the second coming of christ
but
he's he i think he he definitely knows
what he's talking about
i didn't read it but i know it's good i
mean because i know people who have read
it
i didn't learn on bobby fischer
teacher's chess
well the thing is america if you found
it informative then it's a good book for
you
simple there's no like objective
standard some
some methods of instruction are some
methods of instruction are good
whoops
okay than others and
and the reality is you've got to find
what works for you okay let's go
six thank you xor p x for the prime
the tier one rather
i think i should probably take here
because otherwise this position will
never clarify
[Music]
but now
yeah this looks good but i don't think
it is
here's google larry kaufman online and
find the book
it's as simple as that yeah you want to
trade interesting
yeah i'm very slow in creating a passer
here
yeah this is losing unfortunately
i think it's losing
it's very close but it's lost here goes
b3
oh h6 okay wait but now i got this
ah he's got this
[Music]
wow i mean that was just incredible
technique by him as always
ah damn it he
that was a stalemate if he would he
would have promoted but of course he
sees that kind of stuff
thank you scooter
was so close but
i misjudged the move fg i shouldn't have
gone i knew i should have gone for it
but
very bad okay let's sack the pawn
probably shouldn't do that either but
whatever
yeah neither of us is able to win with
white today
okay what do i do here i'm stacked upon
i've done this before but it's not
really
sound it can some do something like this
i think i'm pretty evenly matched with
the bobbin blitz i mean we've both
gotten after each other
yeah okay let's see
okay so v6 knight b3 is what i missed
yeah b6 freaking knight b3
hmm gotta have something here
okay let's do it anyway
maybe be five there a sec a third one
alexis doing well thanks for asking
yeah i misplayed this and i forgot
completely about knight c4
yeah this is lost this is going to be
the first loss of black
unless something crazy happens which is
always possible in the king's indian
but another thing is like my standards
are very high for myself so
i i do feel like producing high quality
content takes more energy than just
mailing it in
and the other reality is and this is a
brutal reality that a lot of people
write coaches in the in the
vain hope that they will offer some sort
of magic bullet and
prevent them from working hard and no
amount of coaching
will be even remotely
beneficial if you're not willing to put
in a certain amount of effort and
approach it with a certain mentality
and a lot of people hope and they know
they lie to themselves they know that
that's the case everybody knows that
that is the case but they
still hope that perhaps a couple of
lessons will give them
some sort of magic pathway to success
and it won't
yes that's what i was referring to how
cars there we go you got it bishop c4 he
wants bishops okay but i can go bishop
f4
the problem is he has this okay he
doesn't do it that's a very
very strange move by him gives me a pawn
i mean i'm still down two pawns but at
least
i've got squares
okay let's not rush that
probably bad move
yeah there's obviously not enough here
for the two pawns
he's probably gonna give one of them up
this king is too safe here
always has he always does these little
simplifying things
that are very hard to play against
never misses this stuff ever
[Music]
talon doesn't play a huge role in the
kind of progress that people want to
have
i get it eric i mean i i get that but
it's just desperation
crazy just played a flawless game there
i don't know what to say
there's some residual chances if he
promotes
but i don't think they work king h1 is
probably
very precise and he'll play
we need shape mate that's right
yeah he's ridiculously good
she just never makes mistakes whoops no
i didn't want to play just
okay let's win let's play d4 and win
it's not really a french player so
okay
wow king d7 i guess it's fine because i
don't have many pieces
what weaknesses are yeah i'll talk i
mean i'll obviously talk about that but
right now i'm focused on the game
we're going to try to create a little
bind here this
just blind completely
hmm
not bad bad okay maybe this is not so
bad
oh god rook b8 yeah now i got to go into
this
which is maybe not terrible let's see so
i should have four is now a threat
this is probably losing unfortunately
incredible
okay let's try this i mean it's risky
but i kind of have to go for it
yeah the last two games are very poor
at least i've got better chances here so
one d4 is the way
but should b8 might be the best move for
him actually it's quite dangerous if he
takes
both are fine daniel and daniel are both
fine
thanks for asking okay so he probably
calculated this accurately and i
don't really have the mental energy to
test him so i'm just too calculated
as well so okay king g8 that's
prophylaxis it makes a lot of sense
so c7 rook ca yeah that's probably i'm
sure that's the best move
yeah there's just nothing
i have one idea
oh real cafe yeah that's that's an
annoying move
maybe this is strong yeah
because i'm i'm sort of forking his uh
um this stroke and the other i'm
threatening to take on f8 with check
which will lead to promotion i
i in these positions there's rook g2
king g2 maybe he sacks a rook
but that that's got to be winning for me
in the end of the day
promise he's got roxy to queen g5 queen
d5
that's dangerous we're going to prime of
it
that might actually end up in a draw
of course finds the most tricky line
oh wait that's just losing for me
actually
so what's that wow this is actually not
easy
i mean this might not even be better for
me it's only against sally reza is that
the case
he's got a huge attack for the rook
which is impossible to defend against
the time that i have
[Music]
a bunch of pawns too
ship a5 is almost made but it's not
queen g3 is
probably fine for me
i mean i have no choice but to repeat if
he wants it
i have no moves i have to repeat because
king f1 coin h3 is also a repetition
and if i go to a dark square then he's
got bishop a5 yeah i know that's
that was the fair result
it was if he was very fortunate there
i'm sure it takes g2 but it is what it
[Music]
is
okay let's play my favorite system i
like this for black
i showed g5
okay never okay let's go here
yeah i'm gonna go go for his throat here
which is i feel like
sometimes he falters
okay he goes h oh yeah i forgot about
this move completely
bishop g4 is interesting though
i guess we'll try it it's unsound i'm
sure but interesting
yeah kind of stuff doesn't work against
elereza
yeah gm isn't really a phd i feel like
there's there's less gms and phds
it's not a bad comparison though
and they're paid about just as poorly
yeah bishop h2 is force but he's worse
they're queen f6 maybe
h3 is also very interesting
i'm not sure again i'm not sure i never
know like these two moves and which one
to play
like i have a tendency to play overly
forcing chess in these positions
so i'm gonna go with queen f6
depends on the jam is is that so
actually yeah let's go queen f6
let's not take too long on that move i
don't want to
spend a minute there
i don't know about that i think elon
musk is
pretty impressive in some ways
oh i've laundered a lot of stuff with
that move
at once queen c6 and 95 i mean it's just
bad
very very bad
if i could castle here that would be
good i can't just a sloppy move
okay let me try to get out of this
it's not glamorous but i think this is
the best way because i can still castle
very sloppy very sloppy
but okay now maybe
get the hell out of there
i'm gonna try to trap his queen if you
guys don't mind
i don't know i'm gonna try to trap his
queen
bishop d7 is the threat it's gonna take
a lot of time for him to find something
here
hopefully
okay so i can repeat with a draw is
there really nothing
uh
[Music]
wow it's so close to trapping the queen
here
like oh my god i'm gonna sell this
okay
let's try this one i can take on d3 and
play but i don't really want to
i want to win i mean i guess knight c4
then knight d3 maybe
95 and that makes sense
and a great deal of it
okay i guess the time has come for me to
relinquish my dreams and ambitions
dreams ambitions
i don't like what i'm done there knight
f3
obviously
there's no time though not that that's
ever stopped earlier isn't it
ali riza what are you going to do about
this move ali riza
okay so alireza congrats on your win but
let me tell you how much you suck and
erisa
all right that was a nice one now we
gotta win another one we gotta tie the
match i gotta go soon
it's been a long day
i was started badly but i played well
there
in the critical stretch
yeah and i always okay so he takes
yeah so here i always forget the one i
think i'm supposed to queen see through
this
i mean if he analyzed it i'm screwed but
i don't know if he did
and i think and euresa
yeah this obviously looks very scary but
i think white is supposed to be good
here
okay but ali riza after f3 knight before
queen alireza
okay
f3 knight b4 is a nasty move
just move the dark dark tile bishop here
a3 or c3 who the hell knows
i don't know i'm going to go with a3
yeah
probably should have gone with c3 oh f3
knight f5 is his idea that's
that's the big idea
and we're going to speed up a little bit
this is not good all of a sudden
damn should have gone 1v3
i don't see a move
okay maybe this
i mean some people play preparation like
ray which is fine with me but
makes them very difficult to play
knight d6 is very nasty move
now which knight probably knight ed6
i gotta speed up but i'm not sure what
to do
we're just going to go with h4
yeah this is this is not the position
you want against him
too many threats and ideas he's
merciless in these types of situations i
mean i have an attack here but it's not
strong enough and he's just gonna crush
me on the queen side
this also probably was a queen oh but
then i've got bishop c1 somehow
oh but then knight d4 that's a very nice
tactic
yeah he's going to see it too oh or even
knight a3
yeah queen b5 just ends the game i guess
i have to no it doesn't know
man
i mean b6 yeah he misses it
now i go here i guess 94 anyways what's
his idea
it's not quite as good as in that line
wait i can go here though oh wait or can
i
i think i can
mighty rizza
oh and there is a fountain is going off
too of course
but i have this
holding on trying to win a game with
white
oh my god
it's so easy to like one fork here or
something like that
e5 bishop d5 i guess just to bail out
oh no no but then he
just could get the hell out of there
almost gotta move
[Music]
yeah i went into this for no good reason
and i'm lost
that was just sad
yeah i mean come on i mean why would i
go into that end game
i mean why would i take the queen just a
stupid decision
winning position that was just a dumb
decision to take going i i knew it too
and i went i
took this queen for no reason just
absolutely bonus decision
absolutely bone had a decision
absolutely ridiculous like completely
winning position there
pathetic
yeah that was pathetic absolutely
so disgrace
okay this is let's go h5
and this might be last one or maybe one
two more
yeah i don't know why i make a move
knowing it's bad but i still make it
sometimes
too tempting to simplify
it's hard to play for white oh it's got
this tactic soon
yeah i've lost threat completely
forgot about this tactic
yes i'm
basically king's indian novice
it's not over over but it's objectively
lost
[Music]
[Music]
i guess we'll try to no but c6 i guess
yeah
this is just sad ruined effort
yeah c6hg bishop a7 amazing
yep
thank you dina for the raid 69
appreciate it
okay so i'm playing all your ass to
finish i'm finishing up
okay so knight f4 let's calculate for a
second
no it doesn't work
or wait i guess i have to try it
thank you khalid and appreciate the sub
it's bishop c5
hmm
okay i guess you can try to take
if this pawn wasn't there i'd be winning
but this one is there
this should be seven is interesting
i'm holding on for now
holding on for now
i'm gonna try this one problem is that
time situation is not in my favor even
though i have more time
okay guess if
i definitely want to go check
this has
probably nothing yeah what about this
check i know this chunk
it's got to be made where's the mate
unbelievable oh wait i can go this way
if he covers it i win
repeat after me shark bread and
butter
incredibly lucky game reality hopefully
that tilts him a little bit
it's a sexy attack though
okay last game guys i gotta go can you
guys tell him last game i gotta
peter i have to go right
peter's probably not here shall we
sleeping
yeah i'm good in these positions you
guys know that i'm good i'm legitimately
good in these positions
okay i always get in trouble here
yeah overall i've been very happy with
my performance in this match
very nice games by both of us also some
very pathetic games
mostly by me but um no i'm not heading
back james should have begun already
i have a workout
that's the reality
that's the sad truth of the matter
20 i think my strength over the board is
26 21.
lovely idea
you know what what sick sexy idea i have
guys
you know what what uh cool idea i mean
it probably doesn't work
go king h1 and the the threat is to go
knight you want to trap the queen
you two are hilarious
i'm sure he will find a defense but yeah
this i actually did see
crap do i want to go bishop before
actually
hmm let me think
it's crazy that there's nothing that
good here
oh no no i don't want to go before
i spent too much time on that
i mean these are very i mean i think
black is better here probably
three pawns for the piece it's too many
the end game
in game
why didn't you move your ass
damned luna i'm sorry to hear that stay
safe
he should not have allowed
i think if he takes and he goes in that
f6 i go bishop d4 okay they're knight g5
obviously
stop the h phone
i mean i can take probably winning there
but
let's go here instead b4 is the idea
a nice move
i'm choking
97 daniel come on
yes we got him okay
good games all there is that was
excellent
um if he got if you had gone king e8
um rookie 7 or v3
all right guys um sorry very sorry
earlier as i
i know it looks like i'm running but i
truly have to go
[Music]